[Music]
this means for the energy sector is that
it's going to be harder and harder for
these companies that find oil and gas in
the United States to move those
commodities to market you know they used
to think oh I just need to hit this big
oil field and they'll have it made now
it's not just about finding the oil then
you have to deal with activists and
politicians and hundreds of other
stakeholders just to get that oil out of
your oil field to somewhere that it can
be used these decisions I think really
harm the industry's ability to plan its
business ten years ago if you were in
the midstream business which is the
pipelines you knew what compliance meant
I think that the Dakota access decision
in particular but also the Keystone
decision really diminish your ability if
you're an executive at a midstream
company to plan your business because
now do you really know what the rules
are I'm not sure you do anymore the
thing to understand about all of these
cases is that that it's they're all a
part of the strategy of keeping it in
the ground or at least that's what it
started out as in which they first tried
to outlaw hydraulic fracturing to
prevent the production of gas and oil
from shale plays well that didn't work
out and so about three years ago they
shifted strategy to preventing trying to
prevent the product from moving to
market so the next leg of the strategy
is to try to shut down the midstream
part of the business the pipeline's
deny the ability to build these
pipelines and move the product to market
as we see more and more of these keep it
in the ground protests that have the
effect of slowing pipeline developments
we really could reach a point where this
oil does stay in the ground because it
just becomes too difficult to get it to
market economically at the prices that
we're seeing right now about $40 a
barrel for oil there's not a lot of
incentive for these companies to go
after the more difficult barrels in
Canada's oil sands province for example
we're seeing the shutdown of
some output hundreds of thousands of
barrels a day of oil production is being
shut in because the operating costs are
too high for them to make a decent
profit I think you have to look at the
decisions in the context of them the
moment in time that we find ourselves
five years ago or even two years ago
even one year ago it probably would be
more likely or not that the oil or the
natural gas might just move a different
way but what we're talking about right
now is creating the space to allow new
sources of energy that we need to power
our economy to fill the gap that
reliance on fossil fuels and these
pipelines leave even though a few years
ago the industry would have said oh you
know don't listen to these guys we rely
on oil and gas to keep the world going
round the reality is becoming more
complicated if you look at the clean
energy economy right now it is truly an
economic powerhouse the clean energy
economy is employing three times the
number of people in the fossil fuel
industries so we're past the tipping
point I mean we have made this shift in
in our economy and and you know of
course you have to address what's
happened recently as a result of the
pandemic there has been a loss of jobs
in the clean energy economy
with investment from public and private
funds these jobs can come roaring back
and and this is these are the checkups
of the future you know we need to help
the workers and coal oil and gas but not
just prop up the companies that continue
to rely on energy sources that aren't
the energy sources of the future I think
some people want you to believe that you
can replace coal fire power plants
solely with solar power and wind
and you really can't do that because
those are still intermittent sources of
power they have not developed the
battery technology the storage
technology yet that allows them to store
the energy and use it when the sun's not
shining or the winds up line so if we
don't have oil and gas pipelines to move
oil and gas from place to place in the
United States we're going to need to
build more high-voltage power lines such
that we can move electricity where it
needs to go we might have the technology
whereby we no longer need to generate
electricity by burning natural gas
instead we're moving more and more
towards solar and wind power and other
alternatives but you can't just generate
that electricity from wind turbines in
the middle of nowhere you need to get it
to market somehow so this becomes
ultimately a policy debate for the
United States do we want more of these
below ground pipelines or do we want
more above ground high-voltage lines for
a while anyway we're gonna need one or
the other and that's the that's the hard
reality that we deal with
[Music]
you